what are gravitational waves let's maybe
start from the basics
we learned gravity from newton
right you you and you were young you
were told that if you jumped up the
earth pulled you down
and
when the apple falls out of the tree
the earth pulls it down
and maybe you even asked your teacher
why but
most of us
accepted that that was newton's picture
the apple falling out of the tree but
newton's theory never told you why the
apple was attracted to the earth
that was a missing in newton's theory
newton's theory also
newton recognized at least one of the
two problems i'll tell you one of them
is there's more than those but
one is why does the earth what's the
mechanism by which
the earth pulls the apple or holds the
moon when it goes around whatever it is
that's not explained by newton even
though he has the most successful theory
of physics ever went 200 and some years
with nobody ever seeing
a violation he accurately describes the
movement of an object falling down to
earth but he's not answering why that
what's yeah yeah because it's a distance
he gives a formula right which which
it's the product of the earth's mass the
apple's mass
inversely proportional to the square the
distance between and then the strength
he called capital g the strength he
couldn't determine but it was determined
100 years later
but no one ever saw a violation of this
until a possible violation which
einstein fixed which was very small that
has to do with mercury going around the
sun
the orbit being slightly
wrong if you calculated by
newton's theory
but so
um like most theories than in in physics
you can have a wonderful one like
newton's theory it isn't wrong
but you have to have a
an improvement on it to answer things
that it can't answer and in this case
einstein's theory is the next step we
don't know if it's
anything like a final theory or even the
only way to formulate it
either
but he formulated this theory
which
which he
released in 1915
he took 10 years to develop but even
though in 1905 he solved three or four
of the most important problems in
physics in a matter of months and then
he spent 10 years on this problem before
he
let it out and it's called general
relativity it's a new theory of gravity
1915 in 1916
einstein
wrote a little paper
where he
did not do some fancy derivation instead
he did
what i would call use his intuition
which he was very good at too
and that is he noticed that if he form
if he wrote the formulas for general
relativity in a particular way
they looked a lot like the formulas for
electricity and magnetism
being einstein he then took the leap
that electricity and magnetism we
discovered only 20 years before that in
the 1880s
have waves of course that's
light and electromagnetic rays radio
waves everything else
so he said if the formulas look similar
then gravity probably has waves too
that's such a big leap by the way i mean
maybe you can correct me but that just
seems so that seems like a heck of a lot
yeah and so that and it was considered
to be a heck of a leap so first that
paper was except for this
intuition was
uh
poorly written had had a serious mistake
it had the factor of two wrong and the
strength of gravity which meant if we
use those formulas we would
and uh
two years later
he wrote a second paper
and in that paper it turns out to be
important for us because in that paper
he not only
fixed his factor of two mistake which he
never admitted he just wrote it fixed it
like he always did and
and then he
told us
how you make gravitational waves what
what makes gravitational waves
and
you might recall in electromagnetism we
make electromagnetic waves in a simple
way you take a plus charge and minus
charge you oscillate like this and that
makes electromagnetic waves
and a physicist named hertz
made a receiver that could detect the
waves and put it in the next room
he saw them and moved forward and
backward and saw that it was wave-like
so
uh einstein said it won't be a dipole
like that it'll be a four-pole thing and
that's what
it's called a quadrupole moment that
gives the gravitational wave so he so
that again by insight not by derivation
that's at the table for what you needed
to do to do it at the same time in the
same year schwartz child not einstein
said there were things like called black
holes so it's interesting that that came
the same so what year was that
was 15.
it it was in parallel
with i did
i should probably know this but did i
say not have any intuition that there
should be such things as black holes
that came from schwart's child oh
interesting
yeah
so schwartz child who was uh
a german theoretical physicist he got
killed in the war i think in the first
world war a year two years later
or so
he's the one that proposed black holes
that there were black holes that feels
like a natural conclusion of uh general
relativity you know
or is that uh
[Music]
well it may seem like it but i don't
know about a natural conclusion it is a
it's a result
of curved space time though right and
it's but it's such a weird result that
you might have to uh yeah it's a special
yeah it's a special case yeah
so uh
i i don't know anyway
einstein then the interesting part of
the story is that einstein then left the
problem most physicists because it
really wasn't uh derived he just made
this
didn't pick up on it or general
relativity much because quantum
mechanics became the thing in physics
and
einstein
uh
only picked up this problem again after
he immigrated to the u.s so he came to
the us in 1932
and i think in 1934 or five
he was working with another physicist
called rosen who he did several
important works with and they revisited
the question
and they
had
a problem that most of us as students
always had that study general relativity
general relativity is really hard
because it's four-dimensional instead of
three-dimensional and if you don't set
it up right you get infinities which
don't belong there that we call them
coordinates singularities
as a name but but if you get these
infinities you don't get the answers you
want and
uh
he was trying to derive now general
relativity out from general relativity
gravitational waves and in doing it he
kept getting these infinities
and so he wrote a paper with rosen that
he submitted to
our most important journal physical
review letters
and
that when it was submitted to physical
review letters it was entitled do
gravitational waves exist a very funny
title to write 20 years after he
proposed they exist
but it's because he had found these
singularities these infinities
and so
the
editor at that time and part of it that
i don't know
is peer review we live and die by peer
review as scientists send our stuff out
and it's we don't know when peer review
actually started
or what what peer review einstein ever
experienced before this time but the
editor of physical review sent this out
for review
he had a choice he could take any
article and just accept it he could
reject it or he could send it for review
i believe the editors used to have much
more power yeah yeah and he was a young
man his name was tate
and he ended up being editor for years
but
uh so he sent this for review
to
a theoretical physicist named robertson
who was also in this field of general
relativity who happened to be on
sabbatical at that moment at caltech
otherwise his institution was princeton
where
einstein was
and he saw that the way they set up the
problem the infinities were like i might
get as a student because if you don't
set it up right in general relativity
you get these
infinities
and so he reviewed the article and told
he gave an illustration that if they set
it up in what are called cylindrical
coordinates these
infinities went away
he's the
editor of
physical review was obviously
intimidated by einstein he wrote this
really not not a letter back like i
would get saying you know you're screwed
up in your paper instead
it was kind of uh
what do you think of the comments of our
[Laughter]
referee einstein wrote back and it's a
well documented letter wrote back a
letter to physical review saying uh i
didn't send you the paper
to send it to one of your so-called
experts i sent it to you to publish
i now i withdraw the paper wow
and he never published again in the in
that journal that was 1936 instead
he
rewrote it
with the fixes that were made changed
the title
and published it in what was called the
franklin review which is the
uh franklin institute in philadelphia uh
which is benjamin franklin institute
which doesn't have a journal now but
did at that time so the article is
published it's the last time he ever
wrote about it
it remained controversial
so it wasn't until
close to 1960 1958 where there was a
conference in
which brought that brought together
the
experts in general relativity to try to
sort out whether there was uh
um
whether it was true that there were
gravitational waves or not
and there was a
very nice
derivation by a british
theorist
from
the heart of the theory that gets
gravitational waves
and that was number one the second thing
that happened at that meeting is richard
feynman was there
and feynman
said well if there's a typical finemen
if there's gravitational waves they need
to be able to do something otherwise
they don't exist so they have to be able
to transfer energy so he made a
idea of a gadonkan experiment that is
just a bar
with a couple rings on it
and then if a gravitational wave goes
through it distorts the bar
and that creates friction on these
little rings
and that's heat and that's energy so
that that meant is that a good idea it
sounds like a good idea yeah it means
that he showed that
with the distortion of space-time you
could transfer energy just by this
little idea
and it was shown theoretically so at
that point
it was
uh
belief theoretically then by
people that gravitational waves should
exist
no and we should be able to detect them
we should be able to detect them except
except that they're very very small
just so what kind of uh there's a bunch
of questions here but what kind of
events
would generate
gravitational waves you have to have
this what i call quadruple moment that
comes about if i have uh
for for example two objects that go
around each other like this like the
earth around the earth around the sun or
the moon around the earth or in our case
it turns out to be two black holes going
around each other like this so how's
that different than basic oscillation
back and forth this is just more common
in nature oscillation is a dipole moment
so it has to be in three-dimensional
space yeah kind of oscillations so you
have to have something that's
three-dimensional that'll give what's
what i call the quadrupole moment that's
just built into this and luckily in
nature you have stuff
and luckily things exist
and it is luckily because the effect is
so small that you could say look i could
take a barbell
and
and spin it right and detect the
gravitational waves but unfortunately no
matter how much i spin it how fast i
spin it it's so i know how to make
gravitational waves but they're so weak
i can't detect them so we have to take
something that's stronger than i can
make otherwise we would do what hertz
did for electromagnetic waves go in our
lab
take a barbell put it on something spin
it ask a dumb question so a a single
object that's weirdly shaped does that
generate gravitational waves so if it's
if it's rotating
sure it it was just much weaker
it's weaker well we didn't know what the
strongest signal would be that we would
see
we targeted seeing something called
neutron stars actually because black
holes we don't know very much about it
turned out we were a little bit lucky
there was a stronger source which was
the black holes well another ridiculous
question so
you say waves what is what does a wave
mean like um
the most ridiculous version of that
question is what does it feel like
to uh ride a wave as you get closer to
the
or
source
it well if you experience a wave imagine
that this is what happens to you
i don't know what you mean about getting
close it comes to you so it's like it's
like uh this light wave or something
that comes through you so when light
hits you it may makes your eyes
detect
i flashed it
what does this do is
it's like going to the amusement park
and they have these mirrors you look in
the smear and you look short and fat and
the one next to you makes you tall and
thin
okay
imagine that you went back and forth
between those two mirrors once a second
that would be a gravitational wave with
a period of once a second
if you did it 60 times a second go back
and forth and
and then that's all that happens it
makes you taller and shorter and fatter
back and forth as it goes through you
at the frequency of the gravitational
wave so
the frequencies that we detect are
higher than one a second but
that's the idea so but uh and the amount
is small amounts are small but
when if you're closer to the
to the source of the wave is it the same
amount
yeah it's it doesn't dissipate it
doesn't dissipate
okay so it's not that fun of an
amusement ride well it it does dissipate
but it doesn't it doesn't it's it's just
it's proportional to the distance right
it's not uh it's not a big power
gotcha so but so
it would be a fun ride if you get a
little bit closer or a lot closer
i mean like i wonder what the
this is a ridiculous question but i have
you here
like the getting fatter and taller
i mean that experience
for some reason that's mind-blowing to
me
it brings
the distortion of space-time to you
i mean space-time is being morphed
right like this is a way right
that how that's so weird and we're in
space so yeah we're in space and it's
moving
i don't know what to do with i mean does
it okay um
how much do you think about the
philosophical implications of
general relativity like that we're in
space time and it can be bent by gravity
like
is that just what it is are we are we
supposed to be okay with this because
like newton
even newton is a little weird right but
that at least like makes sense that's
our physical world you know when an
apple falls it makes sense
but like the fact that entirety of
the space time we're in can bend
well that's uh
that's i i that's really mind-blowing
let me make another analogy this is a
therapy session for me yeah right
another analogy thank you so so imagine
you have a trampoline yes
okay
what happens if you put a marble on a
trampoline it doesn't do anything right
no just saves a little bit but not much
yeah i mean just if i drop it it's not
going to go anywhere
now imagine i put a bowling ball at the
center of the trampoline
now
i come up to the trampoline and put a
marble on what happens
it'll roll towards the bowling ball all
right so what's happened is the presence
of this
massive object distorted the space
that the trampoline did
this is the same thing that happens to
the presence of the earth
the earth and the apple the presence of
the earth affects the space around it
just like the
uh bowling ball on the trampoline yeah
this doesn't make me feel better i'm
referring from the perspective of an ant
walking around on that trampoline
then
some guy just dropped the ball and not
only drop the ball right it's not just
dropping a bowling ball it's making the
the ball go up and down
or doing some kind of oscillation thing
where it's like waves
and that's so fundamentally different
from the experience on being on flatland
and walking around and just finding
delicious sweet things as ant does and
just it just feels like to me from a
human experience perspective
completely it's humbling it's truly
humbling
it's something but we see that kind of
phenomenon all the time
let me give you another example
imagine that you walk up to a a still
pond
yes okay
now i throw
it
you throw a rock in it what happens
the rock goes in sinks to the bottom
fine and these little ripples go out
yeah and they travel
out that's exactly what happens i mean
there's a disturbance
which is the safe
the bowling ball or our black holes and
then the ripples that go out in the
water they're not they don't have any
they don't have the rock any part pieces
of the rock i see the thing is i guess
what's not disturbing about that
is it's a
i mean it's a i guess a flat
two-dimensional surface that's being
disturbed
like for a three-dimensional surface a
three-dimensional space to be disturbed
feels weird it's even worse it's four
dimensional because it's space and time
yeah
so that's why you need einstein is to
make it uh
four-dimensional no
to make it four-dimensional
yeah the same phenomenon and and look at
it in all of space and time
anyway luckily
for you and i and all of us
the amount of distortion is incredibly
small
so it turns out that if you think of
space
itself now this is going to blow your
mind too if you think of space as being
like a material like this table
it's very stiff you know we have
materials that are very pliable
materials that are very stiff so
space itself is very stiff so when
gravitational waves come through it
luckily for us it doesn't distort it so
much that it affects our ordinary life
very much
no i mean that's great
that's great i thought there was
something bad coming no this is great
that's great news so i mean that i mean
perhaps we evolved as a life on earth
do we
so it'd be such that for us this
particular set of uh effects of
gravitational waves uh is not that
significant maybe maybe that's why you
probably used
this effect today
or yesterday
so it's it's pervasive well you mean
gravity or or the way the external
because i only uh curvature of space
curvature of space how i only care
personally as a human right the gravity
of earth but you use it every day almost
oh it's curving
no no no
it's in this thing
every time it tells you where you are
yeah
how does it tell you where you are
it tells you where you are because we
have 24 satellites or some number that
are going around in space and it
asks how long it takes the
being
to go to the satellite and come back the
signal to different ones and then it
triangulates yeah and tells you where
you are and then if you go down the road
it tells you where you are do you know
that if you did that with the satellites
and you didn't use einstein's equations
oh no you you want it you won't get the
right answer that's right and
in fact if you take a road let's say 10
meters wide i've done these numbers and
you ask how long you stay on the road if
you didn't make the correction
for
general relativity this thing you're poo
pooing because you're using every day
uh you'd go off the road and you go mid
road well actually that might be so you
use it so so well
well i think i'm using an android so
maybe and the gps doesn't work that well
so maybe i'm using newton's physics uh
so i need to upgrade to general
relativity um so
gravitational waves and einstein
had uh wait feynman really does have a
part in the story
was that one of the first kind of
experimental pro
proposed detect gravitational well he
did what we call a donkey experiment
that's a thought experiment yes okay not
a real experiment but then after that
then people believe gravitational waves
must exist you can kind of calculate how
big they are there's tiny
and so
people started searching the first idea
that was used was feynman's idea
and the
very end of it and it was to take a
great big
huge bar of aluminum
and then put around and it's a it's made
like a cylinder
and then put around it some very very
sensitive detectors so that if a
gravitational wave happened to go
through it it would go
and you detect this extra strain that
was there and that was this method that
was used until we came along it wasn't a
very good method to use
and what was the
so we're talking about a pretty weak
signal here yeah that's why that method
didn't work so what can you tell the
story of figuring out what kind of
method would be able to detect
this very weak signal of gravitational
waves
so remembering the
remembering what happens if you when you
go to the amusement park yeah that it's
going to do something like
stretch this way and squash that way
squash this way and stretch this way we
do have an
instrument that can detect that kind of
thing
it's called an interferometer
and what it does
is it just basically takes usually light
and the two directions that we're
talking about you send light down one
direction and the perpendicular
direction
and if
nothing changes it takes the same and
the arms are the same length it just
goes down bounces back and if you invert
one compared to the other they cancel so
that nothing happens
but
if it's like the amusement park and one
of the arms got
you know got shorter and fatter so it
took longer to go horizontally than it
did to go vertically
then when they come back when when the
light comes back that comes back
somewhat
out of time
and that basically is the scheme
the only problem is that that's not
a very done very accurately
in general and we had to do it extremely
accurately so what uh
what what's the what's the difficulty of
uh
doing so accurately okay
so the measurement that we have to do
is a distortion in time
how big is it
one it's a distortion that's one part
and 10 to the 21 that's 21 zeros and a
one
okay and this so this is like a delay in
the thing coming back
uh it's a one of them coming back after
the other one but the difference is just
one part and 10 to the 21.
so for that reason we make it big let it
let the arms be long
okay so one part and 10 to the 21.
in our case it's kilometers long so we
have an instrument that kilometers in
one direction kilometers in the other
side kilometers we're talking about four
kilometers four kilometers in each
direction
uh
if you take then one part and 10 to the
21 we're talking about measuring
something to
10 to the minus 18 meters
okay
now to tell you how small that is yeah
the proton yeah the thing we're made of
that you can't go and grab so easily is
10 to the minus 15 meters
so this is 1 1000 the size of a proton
that's the effect size of the effect
einstein himself didn't think this could
be measured have we ever seen
actually he said that
but that's because he didn't
you know anticipate modern lasers and
and techniques that we developed
you